we're going to stay in california where
primary voters have narrowed down the
list of candidates in the november
election at o'keefe is in los angeles
where a high intensity race for mayor
still has a long way to go ed good
morning
dana good morning good to see you
remember each state holds elections a
little differently here in california
they hold open primaries open to members
of both parties if somebody wins 50 in
the first round they win if somebody
doesn't win 50 they go to a runoff in
november they also mostly vote by mail
out here so it's going to take a while
to get final results but let's start
with the la mayor's race closely watched
across the country for trends at least
among democrats congresswoman karen bass
a progressive facing her moderate rival
former republican turned democratic
billionaire real estate developer rick
caruso we caught up with each of them
the other day bass once considered by
joe biden to be his 2020 running mate
says tackling crime homelessness and the
cost of living are her top priorities
caruso has spent at least 40 million of
his own dollars blanketing the airwaves
and he's vying to spend millions more to
win there are also notable congressional
results in california congressman david
valadeo is running second right now but
advancing to a runoff in a district now
drawn to favor democrats he's one of 10
house republicans who voted to impeach
former president donald trump and the
first to face voters since then another
republican to watch out here young kim
in her first term advancing to a runoff
but currently trailing a democratic
opponent in another redrawn district if
these two gop incumbents ultimately lose
in november it's an example of how
redistricting was used by democrats to
keep the republican gains overall across
the country smaller potentially robbing
them of a bigger majority in the house
if they take control one other result
out here in california to watch that was
definitive up in san francisco the
district attorney a guy named chasa
bodine recalled by voters he's losing
his job he was elected in 2019 on a vow
to reform the police but high profile
examples of crime like smash and grab
robberies and anti-asian attacks
inspired the recall campaign and made
accusations he soft on crime remember
most democrats across the country don't
embrace the defund the police movement
or those more bold boulder police
reforms bodine did and residents in at
least one big democratic city said they
don't like them tony
that race in particular may be a
bellwether ed thank you very much